I have kind of two buckets I've got
active and I've got passive Investments
I don't consider anything that's passive
in the acquisition. comom portfolio and
so like there's a variety of like uh
tech companies and kind of like Angel
checks which is very small checks you do
for lots of companies that I have
invested in but I don't consider those
part of my main game those are just some
like businesses that I thought were
really interesting and I was willing to
take a small bet on them but my bread
and butter where I make the vast
majority of my wealth is in me writing
checks that I actively work in and that
is what acquisition. comom is about so
this is an active portfolio